[Música]
[Risas]
Tengo 23 años y estudio un posgrado en
la universidad del Sur de California soy
fotógrafa en conciertos y periodista
creo que lograr tu mejor versión no solo
se trata de tu apariencia sino también
afecta tu interior sé que para mí se
trataba más de confianza y de cómo me
sentía conmigo misma de alguna manera
Eres capaz de reconocerlo en otras
personas que han pasado por eso espero
ver algunas fotos vergonzosas con las
que puedas relacionarme un poco si de
esto saliera una cita no me molestaría
[Música]
[Risas]
basta esto es tan gracioso realmente me
estoy divirtiendo amo el perro me
encanta el Chihuahua Qué lindo este
corte es un tipo tazón No lo sé eso lo
era todo lo veo bastante aquí veamos
concursante 2 El buen estilo Justin
Bieber me gusta que tenemos dos opciones
aquí que bien tenemos una camiseta sin
mangas y una camiseta como un pequeño
portafolio de modelaje Oh los frenos
Siempre quise frenos estoy muy celosa
cuando era niña rogué por ellos y nunca
los tuve Por qué quería frenos No lo sé
porque todos los tenían eran muy
populares Este es el Museo de Cera de
Madame tuso me gusta el puño arriba me
acabo de dar cuenta de que es una camisa
de gambas estaban muy de moda eran así
los zapatos gruesos de patinador esto
debe haber sido el 2008 9 de seguro vaya
está muy empleada Oh las gafas es algo
por lo tal vez se sientan inseguros
ahora pero también querían anteojos
cuando era niña me gusta esta sonrisa
apenas aquí Muchas gracias por
permitirme verlas me siento muy
privilegiada
[Música]
veamos
bueno desafortunadamente voy a eliminar
al número 3
me encanta Su carisma pero los
auriculares me dicen que probablemente
escuches música electrónica ahora y eso
es un poco preocupante
Oh Dios mío eres genial Hola encantada
de conocerte un placer no escucho esa
música sí
puedes darme un poco de contexto de la
imagen esto es de cuando viene por
primera vez a los Estados Unidos soy
filipino
eso es tan genial como 13 años
Sí igualmente
uno puede estarme un poco de contexto de
la imagen como el collar brillante el
perro Cuántos años tenía creo que fue
como en sexto grado Ese es mi perro
llamado Rafi tiene unos ojos grandes y
brillantes soy de Hawaii y mi hermana
siempre me decía que debía dejarme
crecer el cabello para ser uno de esos
chicos surfistas simplemente se
convirtió en eso y el resto es historia
es Genial que seas de Hawaii Yo también
vivía ahí por un año pero Sí
definitivamente veo lo del luxorcista sí
estaba muy de mota en este momento y en
especial no para mí
bien número dos años tenías en esa foto
o diría que mi primer año de Secundaria
Cómo lograste cambiar tu apariencia en
el pasado todos usamos el corte de víver
antes de que fuera el corte
antes era el corte de facto pero sí
obviamente muchas cosas han cambiado
desde entonces no me gusta el rosa y
tengo otro corte de cabello número
cuatro Esta foto es de octavo grado es
la impresión que en octavo grado estaba
en mi era de gregli de seguro solo me
importaba Warcraft Así que probablemente
es obvio
mis hermanos solían jugar eso durante
ocho horas al día en la secundaria lo
acabo de deducir por la foto lo sabía te
reconocí Pues cómo mejoraste tu
apariencia
empecé a preocuparme por las chicas
Entonces sí comencé a ir al gimnasio
comencé a tratar de cuidar mi cabello
empecé a usar depop
sílvester Stallone eres un gran
admirador suyo en realidad sí soy de
Filadelfia Así que sí amo las películas
de Rocky bien cómo crees que has
cambiado desde esa foto yo no uso las
gafas eso es un buen comienzo y solía
ser de baja estatura pero crecí un poco
y las trenzas desaparecieron número 6
qué edad tenías en esta foto 12 creo por
la escuela secundaria Esa era la foto de
mi pasaporte anterior y apenas expiró
hace unos pocos años Así que todavía
viajaba con eso Por lo que recibí
algunas miradas el mío igual pero hace
dos años cuando tenía una foto de cuando
tenía 12 y en el aeropuerto decían no
así Y qué te hizo querer mejorar sucedió
naturalmente o pusiste esfuerzo en ello
para ser honesto sucedió de forma
natural ya no uso anteojos ahora uso
lentes de contacto y luego poco a poco
fui sintiéndome orgulloso de mi
apariencia la pubertad es algo genial
[Risas]
ni siquiera tengo buenas razones para
eliminar alguno todos ellos están en su
mejor versión bueno desafortunadamente
eliminaré el concursante número dos
No sé todavía me pregunto si tendrá el
mismo estilo de patinador que tenía Allí
estoy emocionada de ver
Dios mío eres tan genial A dónde voy sí
puedes venir aquí Hola encantada de
conocerte encantado una vez que vi a
todos supe que se había terminado el
juego todos son súper guapos allí atrás
quien quiera que elijas estarás bien
razón
es como un corte de 180 grados tu
cabello está tan arreglado
había como una docena de cortes
diamantes en la secundaria todos lucían
el mismo cabello lo recuerdo
voy a eliminar al concursante número 5
no me gustan las películas de acción en
absoluto especialmente Rocky
eso ni siquiera es una buena razón pero
es todos los que tengo
[Música]
fue en ese momento que supo que se había
equivocado
gracias Cómo te va encantado de
conocerte sí vaya me encanta el tuyo
Eres me gusta tu sonrisa gracias
todos ustedes son Tan guapos y tan
geniales concursante número uno dijiste
que solías vivir en Hawaii qué te trajo
los Ángeles
sí estuve rodeado de agua unos 19 años
de mi vida y tuve fiebre isleña así que
me fui a la universidad
recibí mi educación y he estado viajando
por todo el mundo Cuál es el mejor lugar
que visitaste me gustó Japón es
divertido y la comida y es increíble sí
Japón está en mi lista de deseos
deberíamos ir sí Hola veamos dijiste que
jugabas mono de Warcraft sigues jugando
mucho hoy en día eso es lo que recuerdas
Sí yo juego bien soy aficionado juego
Lic pero también hago cosas de gente
cool créeme no aprecio que juegues solía
jugar Halo y he jugado lee un par de
veces en mi vida en serio te gustó sí
aunque soy una persona a quien le gusta
más salir y hablar con otras personas
bien no no no no estoy diciendo que no
lo sabría No sabría cómo es eso
bien dijiste que esta es una foto de
pasaporte y creciste viajando mucho sí
mi mamá hizo énfasis en que mi hermano y
yo hubiéramos diferentes culturas fue
algo realmente que aprecié qué haces
ahora en qué trabajas eres estudiante me
gradué hace un par de años en
kinesiología con énfasis en fisioterapia
No eso es tan dulce me encanta qué tan
importante es el fitness para ti me
ejercito unos cuatro días a la semana no
es muy importante para mi vida pero me
gusta mantenerme activa camino a todos
lados porque no tengo auto viviendo en
Los Ángeles Vengo de San Francisco o
nunca necesité un auto allí y luego
cuando me mudé aquí pensé el transporte
público será como en San Francisco pero
no lo fue lo más mínimo y es horrible
así que entiendo por completo la
situación sé qué tan difícil es llegar a
cualquier parte sin un auto creo que mi
primer eliminado en esta ronda será el
concursante número
mencionaste el fitness en tu vida y no
busco tener una pareja de gimnasio me
encanta hacer ejercicio por mi cuenta
pero no lo sé veo esa gente en el
gimnasio y no soy yo
Hola Soy Victoria encantada
sigue siendo lindo pero sí fue un placer
Fue genial conocerte adiós
saben que no creo que tenga una buena
razón para esto pero creo que eliminaré
al concursante número 6
no hay una buena razón lo siento
muchísimo
Hola Dios mío te ves tan diferente Así
es Hola cómo me gustaron las gafas
gruesas y El pequeño mechón de cabello
verdad pasamos por esto ni siquiera has
visto la mía todavía es peor que
cualquiera de estas bueno Fue genial
conocerte
Así que has tomado tu decisión final
gran error
[Música]
Hola hola
encantada de conocerte tu estilo están
genial lo habías mencionado el Dipo
verdad sí ahí es donde compras tus cosas
Sí eso es muy económico Sí
definitivamente sostenible también me
gusta mucho ahorrar bien solo
tiendas de segunda mano
Qué gusto conocerte lo mismo diga Sí
definitivamente voy a escribirle un
texto si le gusto aprovecharé la
oportunidad y la tomaré estoy muy
orgullosa de mi decisión lo sabía tuve
una intuición un presentimiento debería
girarla sí adelante Ah muy bien lo haré
[Música]
Los humildes comienzos de seguro nos
parecemos somos idénticos
nos parecemos sí pensaba que tenía muy
buen sentido de la moda
está justo ahí puedo verlo quieres darme
tu número o tu Instagram batería baja
vaya qué bien
qué tienes delante de ti qué es eso por
mi cumpleaños fue una lección de
humildad que ellos vieran mi foto porque
son cosas que escondo de la gente sí
mejoró de la mejor manera posible es
hermosa lo que se están perdiendo es que
tenía una unicef antes de esto pero la
comida se ve bien me dio hambre